in this video i'm going to show you how
to get that old retro film effect look
like we see in grindhouse films
in after effects without any third-party
plugins
hey there my name is cameron with motion
science
and today i'm going to show you how to
create an old retro film effect that we
see in grindhouse films from the 60s and
70s it's a really awesome effect it
doesn't require any third-party plugins
and it's easy to do let's jump in
so let's start by creating our types
we're going to select the type tool and
we're going to type out
grind house
and of course you can type out anything
you want to put in here i'm just going
to use the word grindhouse i'm going to
select align
center horizontally and vertically and
i'm going to select a type phase called
hot pursuit that i found searching the
web for a grindhouse typeface and i'm
also going to increase the
vertical
scale of the typeface next thing we're
going to do is go down here to color
correction and we're going to select
fill and i'm going to select this color
here it's kind of like a nice
desaturated pink set a keyframe for the
color at 1 12. we'll go back to the
beginning of our timeline and we're
going to set another keyframe and we're
going to make our color more of a red
color i noticed that if you look at
old 70s retro titles whenever something
whenever type fades up from
zero transparency it always typically
starts with a red
tint to that type face and then it kind
of
levels out to the color it is so even if
this typeface was white if it was 100
white when it finished
i would still start it at a red fill
color and we're going to play around
with the opacity keyframes and take the
zero percent opacity back to zero so you
can see now we're already getting
something interesting right so we're
fading from zero to 100 percent
we're fading from transparent to opaque
and from red to pink
i'm going to create a new
null object and we're going to set a
expression on this null object which is
wiggle parentheses 24 comma
1. 24 times per second we're going to
have an amplitude of 1.
which means that this null is going to
just kind of wiggle around the screen so
we're going to go ahead and parent
grindhouse type to the null and you can
see it's a very subtle effect but
there's a little bit of
wiggle to our type now
it's got that old film shake to it let's
add a second null and we'll parent our
first null to the second null
and to this null we're going to add a
wiggle expression as well so wiggle
parentheses
and one time per second at an amplitude
of seven
we're going to have
this type move around screen so this
just creates some secondary motion that
just makes it way more interesting to
look at
and more analog
next thing we're going to do is add a
new solid
and we are going to call the solid white
dust and we're going to go ahead and
click ok
and to this solid we're going to apply
the effect noise and grain fractal noise
and we just have to adjust a few
settings here one being contrast we're
going to
bump contrast up to
about
600 and brightness will also take down
and brightness will take down to
negative
260
and then we're going to alter option
click on evolution
and put in an expression here
that is wiggle
parentheses
24 times per second at a value of
10
000
we get
what i will call white dust for our
screen so it's starting to get that kind
of old
film look to it now next thing we're
going to do
is
set this to a transfer mode of screen so
it's
white dust sitting over the top of our
tight face so you can see it's starting
to look pretty retro pretty grind house
light
next thing we're gonna do is we're gonna
duplicate our white dust and we're gonna
rename this
black dust and to make the dust black
all we have to do is change the
brightness from negative 260 to
a positive 260. so now we have black
dust on white and we will change the
transfer mode to multiply and you can
see that black dust sitting over the top
of the type face there if i turn it off
and on
it's easier to see and if we preview
this now we've got some nice white dust
some nice black dust
and it's really looking retro so let's
take this a step further let's add a new
adjustment layer call this adjustment
layer effects and we'll go to blur and
sharpen and we'll go down here to
gaussian blur
and we're going to crank up the
blurriness to something
like six it'll depend on the size of
your composition
we're gonna go to stylize glow
and we're going to crank up the radius
to something like 175
and turn down the intensity to something
like 0.3 so we have a nice soft glow on
our tight now again let's take this one
step further let's go to layer
new adjustment layer and this one we'll
call blur and we'll go to effect
blur and sharpen camera lens blur
and we're going to open up the effect
and alter option click on blur radius
and type in wiggle parentheses
24 times per second a amplitude of 10.
i'm also going to bring the in and out
point of this layer
much closer together so that only during
this point in the timeline we get a kind
of frenzied focus effect like the
projector is losing focus and trying to
maintain or regain its focus
looking pretty dope now you could call
it good at this point i think it looks
really awesome
or you could take it one step further
and to do that we could add a new solid
and i found that i really liked this
kind of desaturated blue color
that i'm going to dial in right here
when going for these retro looks we want
to be really careful to stay away from
saturated colors
so i can take this to the bottom and now
we've got instead of the type on black
which is typically where i would tend to
go we've got the type on a desaturated
blue
which looks really nice
looks very grind house very 70s i'm
going to go ahead and lock that layer
turn it back off so that's one approach
you can go
another way you can take this even
further
is we can take the type layer and we can
go to create
create shapes from text what this does
is it turns off our type layer it
creates shape layers inside of after
effects with our
type so what i'm going to do is create a
new group i'm going to select all of the
different letters of the word drop them
into one group and to that group i'm
going to apply a repeater
now the default for a repeater is always
to
offset the position of x by a hundred
we're gonna change that to one and we're
gonna change the position to one as well
and we're going to set the number of
copies
out of something like 20.
we're also going to take this
shape layer and we are going to adjust
the fill color to make it darker
so we'll make it kind of a deep red
we'll turn our text layer back on which
is sitting on top
so now when everything fades on this
text has this kind of faux
3d shadow
to it
i'm gonna go ahead and turn down the
number of copies to something like 16 so
it's not quite as extruded the more
copies you have the more extrusion will
appear on screen
we're also going to take that type layer
one more time create shape layers from
type and i'm doing this because i want
to turn off the fill and turn off
the effect and turn on the stroke and
the stroke we're going to make the same
color as our
extruded layer beneath and this is just
going to make that
type on top stand out a little bit
better
so we'll go ahead and take a look at
this
and i'm really digging it
go ahead and turn on that blue
background layer and see how that looks
and either way it looks great over black
over the desaturated blue
maybe it's over an orange color a lot of
different ways you could go with the
colors on this one and that is super
cool that my friends is how you create a
retro grind house film look i hope that
you really enjoyed this lesson as much
as i loved teaching it so please let me
know if you have any questions in the
comments below i'd love to answer them
for you hit that like button if you
enjoyed this video and please subscribe
to this channel it helps other people
find this channel as well if you're
looking to upgrade your design skill set
master the art of style and execute like
a pro i have a course called stylecraft
that you can check out at
motionscience.tv you can also learn more
about this course by clicking the link
in the description below as always
thanks for watching my name is cameron
and this is motion science
[Music]